it seems quite likely that yesterday was
the day that open AI launched the full
training run of GPT 5 I've gone through
every Source I can find to bring you the
most reliable information on what that
means including possibly every public
comment on the topic from open aai an
exclusive interview with a hardware CEO
and tons of my own analysis plus I'm
going to find time to throw in a
practical tip that you can use literally
every time you open gbt and a bonus
darly discovery that I really enjoy but
let's start with these two tweets and
the first clue that the fullscale gp5 is
being trained comes from the president
and co-founder of open AI Greg Brockman
now first a little bit of context open
aai typically trains smaller models of
about a thousandth the size before they
do a full training run they then gather
insights from these smaller models
before doing the full training run so
that's the backdrop to open AI in
brockman's words scientifically
predicting and understanding the
resulting systems that being done what
they're now building is maximally
harnessing all their Computing resources
they're Gathering all of their ideas
together and scaling Beyond precedent
translated they are training their
biggest model yet we'll get to
parameters data and capabilities in a
moment but first what's this other tweet
this comes from Jason way a top open AI
researcher a few hours after brockman's
tweet he said there's no adrenaline rush
like launching a massive GPU training
and this got plenty of salutes in the
reply from other open AI employees now
for context this does not mean that
we're imminently going to get GPT 5 GPT
4 took around 3 months to train and then
there was the safety testing I'm
actually going to end this video with my
exact prediction of when I think they're
going to release GPT 5 but first here is
a little bit more supporting evidence
that they are currently training GPT 5
openai updated their blog to say that
applications for the red teaming Network
have closed and that those red teamers
would know about the status of their
applications by the end of last year
what that means is that the red teamers
are now in place to start safety testing
the new model now you might say what's
the point of having those red teamers in
place if it's still going to be training
for 2 to 3 months well before a model is
fully trained it goes through various
checkpoints think of them a bit like a
video game save what that also means is
that in effect open AI will have a GPT
4.2 before they have a gp5 indeed Greg
Brockman going back to April of last
year said that it might be one of those
checkpoints that open AI released first
he said that it's easy to create a
Continuum of incrementally better AIS
such as by deploying subsequent
checkpoints of a given training run and
he explicitly contrasted that approach
and said it would be very unlike our
historical approach of infrequent major
model upgrades but remember that even
before those checkpoints open AI would
have already gotten a glimpse of GPT 5's
capabilities from those smaller earlier
versions of the model indeed samman back
in November said that he was privileged
to be in the room when they push back
the veil of ignorance I'm super excited
uh I can't imagine anything more
exciting to work on and on a personal
note like four times now in the history
of open ey the the most recent time was
just in the last couple coup weeks I've
gotten to be in the room um when we sort
of like push the front the sort of the
veil of ignorance back and the front
tier of Discovery forward and getting to
do that is like the professional honor
of a lifetime it all points to open AI
in November and December having trained
those smaller versions of GPC 5 again
with the purpose of scientifically
predicting and understanding the
resulting GPT 5 system so they know it's
going to be good but just how good and
how big and what are these new or old
ideas that they're going to incorporate
well one thing that seems almost certain
is that they're going to incorporate a
way to let GPT 5 think for longer in
other words it's going to lay out its
reasoning steps before solving a
challenge and have each of those
reasoning steps checked internally or
externally here's samman a few days ago
at Davos what it means to verify or
understand what's going on is going to
be a little bit different than people
think right now uh I actually can't look
in your brain and look at the 100
trillion synapses uh and try to
understand what's happening in each one
and say okay I really understand why
he's thinking what he's thinking you're
not a black box to me um but what I can
ask you to do is explain to me your
reasoning I can say you know you think
this thing why and you can explain first
this then this then there's this
conclusion then that one and then
there's this and I can decide if that
sounds reasonable to me or not and I
think our AI systems will also be able
to do the same thing they will be able
to explain to us in natural language the
steps from concl from A to B and we can
decide whether we think those are good
steps and a few days before that samman
told Bill Gates that that might involve
asking GPT 4 or GPT 5 the same question
10,000 times you know when you look at
the next two years what what do you
think some of the the key Milestones
will be multimodality will definitely be
important weed speech in speech out
speech in speech out images eventually
video clearly people really want that we
launched images and audio and it had a
much stronger response than we expected
we'll be able to push that much further
but maybe the most important areas of
progress will be around reasoning
ability right now gp4 can reason in only
extremely limited ways and also
reliability if you ask gp4 most
questions 10,000 times one of those
10,000 is probably pretty good but it
doesn't always know which which one and
you'd like to get the best response of
10,000 each time that increase in
reliability will be important and at
this point Watchers of my channel will
know exactly what he's referring to both
of those approaches checking your
reasoning steps and sampling up to
10,000 times are incorporated into open
ai's let's verify step-by-step paper now
I'm not going to dive into the details
of let's verify in this video cuz I've
got at least two previous videos on the
topic but notice in the paper how many
times they sample GPT 4 the chart shows
what happens when you sample the model
over a thousand times and pick out the
best responses and notice something
about this process supervised way of
doing things the results are continuing
to go up I can't resist showing you a
quick example of the reasoning steps
broken down into separate lines and
essentially a verifier looking in and
checking which steps are accurate or
inacurate the answers for whom each step
in the reasoning process got a thumbs up
were the ones submitted and the results
were dramatic essentially this process
of sampling the model thousands of times
and taking the answer that had the
highest rated reasoning steps doubled
the performance in mathematics and no
this didn't just work for mathematics it
had dramatic results across the stem
fields and remember this was using GPT 4
as a base model not GPT 5 and it was
only 2,000 samples not 10,000 like
samman talked about so this is the
evidence I would present to someone who
said that llms have PE if open AI can
incorporate through parallelization a
way to get the model to submit and
analyze 10,000 responses the results
could be truly dramatic indeed the let's
verify paper from openai repeatedly
cited this earlier deep mine paper on
solving math problems with process-based
feedback and for coding we know Alpha
code 2 from Google deepmind use Mass
sampling approach to get an 87th
percentile score on a coding contest in
other words it beat 87% of participants
in this code forces coding challenge for
context the gp4 that we got scored
around the fifth percentile a score of
400 in the code forces challenge these
numbers are a little out of date but
Alpha code 2 would have scored around
here expert or candidate Master Level or
to just translate everything if they
find a way to let gp5 think it could be
night and day in terms of performance
for coding mathematics and stem but just
how big will gp5 be that's doing all of
this parallel thinking well for AI
insiders I interviewed Gavin Uberti the
CEO and co-founder of etched AI which
I've also talked about on this channel
he is a 21-year-old Dropout from Harvard
University and on his LinkedIn profile
it says he's building the hardware for
superintelligence in the interview he
guessed that GPT 5 would have around 10
times the parameter count of GPT 4
according to leaks GPT 4 has around 1.5
to 1.8 trillion parameters but just
quickly what did he mean when he said
that he expects that to come from a
combination of a larger embedding
Dimension more layers and double the
number of experts well think of the
embedding Dimension as being about how
granular the training can be about each
token and its context a bigger embedding
Dimension means more granularity and
Nuance about each token and doubling the
number of layers allows a model to
develop deeper pattern recognition it
allows it to see more complex pattern
within patterns within patterns more
highlights from that interview will be
coming on AI Insiders on patreon in the
coming weeks but during this video on
GPT 5 I promised you two interludes one
focused on Dar 3 and one a practical tip
for using chat anytime well here is the
first of those two interludes focused on
a particular Quirk of Dar 3 I say that
but this trick also works for Mid
Journey now many of you might have
noticed a trend on Tik Tok Reddit
Twitter and and YouTube shorts where
people post an image and then make it
progressively more intense let's say
well here's something arguably even more
quirky I got the original idea from
Peter werf for on Twitter and decided to
make it more intense but first I asked
draw an image of a London scene but
don't use lampost in the image and lo
and behold we get dozens of lampost I
mean in this one we have a lampost
coming down from the sky and what does
gp4 say in analyzing these it says that
these are two images of a London Street
Scene without lampost so then I said now
make these images with even fewer
lampost stripping any lampost references
completely and here were the results as
you can see on the right there's barely
a lampos in sight and as GPT 4 says
these images were created with complete
omission of any lampost references then
I said delete absolutely everything that
pertains to a lampost and I don't know
about you but I can't see any lampost
left and finally I said take this to the
Max and give me an image that someone
could not picture a lampost existing
within even in their wildest imagination
now I think it's pretty cute that the
lampost persisted throughout these
images and I suspect that the deeper
reason is that the caption training that
Dar 3 got didn't have many examples of a
mission they used web captions and
synthetic captions but I doubt there
were many examples of people saying this
image does not contain X but speaking of
modality the first thing they want to
fix apparently for GPT 5 is the real
time nature of the voice interaction at
the moment there is quite a bit of time
to First token latency in other words it
takes a bit too long to reply here's Sam
Alman speaking last week I think there's
all sorts of the current stuff that
people complain about like the voice is
too slow and you know it's not real time
and that'll get better this year I I
think where we're headed and then I'll
talk about this year is we're headed
towards the way you use a computers to
talk to it the operating system of of a
computer in some sense is is close to
this idea that you're like working
inside of a chat experience when he
mentioned using an llm as an operating
system he was drawing on Andre Kathy's
Vision I've talked about it before but
notice at the top that it's video In and
Out audio in and out and it's not like
open AI are hiding it they want as much
text image audio and video data as they
can get their hands on they also want
what I'm going to call reasoning data
data that expresses human intention they
call it now I didn't notice that phrase
at the time of this blog post in
November but it fits in clearly with
what I was saying earlier about let's
verify think about it how would you make
a model agentic able to solve more
complex challenges well if gbt 5 gets
loads of data about people laying out
plans full of human intention gbt 5
could learn to imitate those schemes and
plans and maybe have a verifier
internally or externally judging those
reasoning steps now as for the question
of whether those reasoning steps
Faithfully represent what the model is
internally calculating that will have to
be for another day this paper from
anthropic back in July said that as
models become larger and more capable
they actually produce less faithful
reasoning on most tasks we study that
doesn't mean getting the answer wrong
more often it means outputting reasoning
steps that don't actually reflect what
it's internally calculating so GPT 5 may
end up being an excellent productivity
assistant while still being somewhat
inscrutable on a deeper level just
quickly before we leave data I think
there's one thing that we can safely say
which is that there will be much more
multilingual data in Gypsy 5 training
set open AI have formed so many data
Partnerships including with people like
the Icelandic government and there are
so many more multilingual data sets
being open-sourced that I think it's
almost inevitable that there will be a
dramatic forward step in GPT 5's
multilingual abilities partly this is a
safety thing too with open AI wanting
its red teamers to be fluent in more
than one language models are notorious
iously easier to jailbreak in different
languages and it looks like open AI are
working hard on that front but there is
one language that I bet you didn't know
gp4 can already speak and that's the
language of according to this
fascinating paper from Tokyo GPT 4 can
almost perfectly handle unnatural
scrambled text now you might already
know that humans have this ability if
the first and last letter of a word is
the same you can often still recognize
the word but GPT 4 and obviously GPT 5
will be able to go a step further even
if the first and last letter are
different if a word is completely
scrambled it can recover the sentence I
tested it out and indeed it works just
look at how utterly garbled this
sentence is for me and you that would be
almost complete gobble but gp4 was able
to recognize what I'm saying so that is
the Practical tip that I also wanted to
give you in this video If you have a
quick request of gpc4 don't bother going
back and spending 30 seconds
correcting all your typos trust me I've
been guilty of this in the past because
I love perfect English but if you have a
lesser or two out of place don't worry
it will understand to be honest if it
can unscramble this it can understand
your typo of the word there you're
missing comma and all the rest of it so
save yourself 30 seconds and don't even
bother correcting your typos but now
it's time for me to finally give my
prediction for when gpc5 is going to be
released for the last few weeks I've
honestly thought it would be around
September of this year but now I think
it will be toward the end of November of
2024 and no that's not just because that
would be the 2-year anniversary of the
release of chat GPT the original version
first let me clarify that I don't think
they will release the full capabilities
of GPT 5 on the first go as mentioned I
think they'll release different
checkpoints different functionalities as
we head into 2025 but what explains the
delay from now when they're training it
all the way to November M well first of
all as mentioned it does take a few
months to train a model the size of GPC
5 yes they might be able to use say
100,000 h100 gpus from Nvidia but
training a model has hiccups and of
course the model will be much larger but
let's say that takes around 2 months
that would bring us to the end of March
now here's the key Point Sam Alman has
boasted many times in the past about how
they tested GPT 4 for 6 to 8 months
before releasing it it would be pretty
awkward for open AI to have even less
safety testing for GPT 5 so add 6 months
to the end of March and you get to the
end of September of course add 8 months
and you get to the end of November so
why end of November rather than end of
September well I think open aai will
want to steer clear of what will be an
incredibly contentious American election
if they release even an alpha version of
gpc5 with say video and audio before
that election they could come under
incred credible Flack as they say on
their website they're still working to
understand how effective their current
tools might be for personalized
persuasion that would be stepping into a
Minefield in the recent New Hampshire
election we already saw rooc calls
imitating Joe Biden what a bunch of Maly
we know the value of voting Democratic
when our votes count it's important that
you save your vote for the November
election so November 30th as well as
being a symbolic date would stay clear
of that election you might say what
about 2025 but I think the incentives of
Mok will prevent them delaying too long
in not too long we might be getting the
release of Gemini Ultra not to mention
Gemini 2 ultra and of course llama 3
from meta announced by Zuckerberg when
everyone else has caught up they might
feel compelled to release the next model
and anthropic might choose a similar
time to release Claude 3 here is the CEO
of anthropic Dario amade giving his
rough predictions for GPT 5 and Claude 3
what do you think happens on the next
major training run for l
my guess would be you know nothing truly
insane happens Say in any training run
that that that you know happens in 2024
you know to really invent new science
the ability to to cure diseases ability
to make to make bio yeah the ability to
make bioweapons yeah maybe someday that
the Dyson fears the the least impressive
of those things I think you know will
happen I I would say no sooner than 2025
maybe
2026 um I think we're just going to see
in 202 for crisper more commercially
applicable versions of the models that
exist today like we you know we've seen
a few of these generations of jumps I
think in 2024 people are certainly going
to be surprised like they're going to be
surprised at how much better these
things have gotten but it's it's not
going to quite Bend reality yet of
course I have to say at the end of this
video that no one truly knows not even
open AI what gpc5 will be like as samman
recently said until we go train that
model gpc5 it's like a fun guessing game
for us I can't tell you here's exactly
what it's going to do that GPT 4 didn't
and here's Greg Brockman with a similar
message right that is the biggest theme
in the history of AI is that it's full
of surprises every time you think you
know something you scale it up 10x turns
out you knew nothing um and so I think
that we as a Humanity as a species are
really exploring This Together MH and
then we get cryptic messages like this
from senior members of open aai Ben new
house says he's hiring at openai and
we're building what I think could be an
industry defining 0o to1 product that
leverages the latest and greatest from
our upcoming models IE gp5 and two other
openai employees replied like this this
product will change everything and what
they said of course it would be pure
speculation to guess what they mean with
this so those were my predictions I try
to base them on evidence rather than
idle speculation I do try not to be lazy
like gypt 4 has in the past been accused
of being if you like this kind of thing
I would invite you to see more exclusive
premium content on AI Insiders on
patreon but for everyone watching to the
end I want to thank you so much for
being here and I want to wish you a
wonderful day